of last night's initial launch attempt
tonight's liftoff is set for 8
16 and 14 seconds p.m central time
9 16 and 14 seconds p.m eastern time
at the start of a five minute launch
window the weather for tonight's launch
just
couldn't be better it is absolutely
pristine at wallops island just a few
clouds at 4 500 feet
winds out of the northwest at four knots
temperature of about 58 degrees
fahrenheit
everything is green across the board and
there is the target
for the artemis program coming up for
nasa the moon
with sites set on that destination to
land
the first woman and the next man on the
surface of the moon
in 2024 good evening from mission
control in houston and the international
space station flight control room here
at the johnson space center
flight controllers here are watching
over the station as they do
24 7 365 tending to its systems and the
three crew members comprising the
expedition 63 crew
we'll talk more about them in a moment
back at the wallops flight facility
northrop grumman engineers are
monitoring the countdown at this hour
from the range control center
they will be in control of the
nine-minute climb to orbit for the
two-stage antares rocket from liftoff
to the point when the cygnus resupply
craft separates
from the vehicle's second stage they
just completed a poll of all of the
engineering positions just a moment or
two ago
everyone is go for launch in dulles
virginia
another team of northrop grumman
engineers are on duty as well
ready to take over the flight of cygnus
after spacecraft separation under the
direction of mission director
zach dwyer they'll be following all of
cygnus's maneuvers
during its three-day trek to the
international space station
back here in mission control in houston
the orbit 3 team of flight controllers
is on duty with the station crew members
well into their sleep period for the
night
as was the case last night flight
director tj creamer is back in charge
presiding over the orbit 3 team
this evening excuse me
cygnus's launch was originally scheduled
for this past tuesday night
but a forecast of inclement weather at
wallace for both tuesday and wednesday
night pushed the initial launch attempt
to last night and with the weather
finally cooperating last night the
countdown reached
the two-minute 40-second mark before the
launch was scrubbed
we'll talk more about that in a moment
at
the present time we're sitting at
t-minus 28 minutes and counting
there are no issues being worked by the
launch control team at wallops
as we mentioned last night each launch
of a cygnus cargo craft carries with it
a tradition for northrop grumman
the naming of the spacecraft after a
noted space explorer who contributed
to human space exploration the cygnus
being launched tonight is named for
nasa astronaut kultner chavla who twice
flew into space first
on the sts-87 mission aboard the space
shuttle columbia in 1997
and then on the ill-fated sts-107
mission aboard colombia
in 2003 in which she and her six
crewmates lost their lives during entry
culpner the first nasa astronaut of
indian and south asian descent
being honored on this mission of cygnus
to the international space station
the antares rocket being launched
tonight is a two-stage rocket that will
propel the cygnus cargo craft to its
preliminary orbit
to begin the chase to reach the
international space station in the wee
hours
monday morning but before we look ahead
let's look back 24 hours to last night's
postponement and with us this evening by
phone to discuss all of these
developments returning tonight with us
is christina hellona the northrop
grumman antares system engineering
program manager christina thanks for
joining us once again this evening
thank you rob i'm excited to be back
with you and our nasa tv viewers to see
a
successful antares launch and
signification to the national space
station
everything's looking great tonight but
before we get into all of that
walk us through last night's scrub what
was the cause how did northrop grumman
remedy the issue that brought us
to this evening's launch attempt
no problem rob so last night during the
countdown the computer auto aborted at
approximately t
minus two minutes and 49 seconds when it
received an off
nominal reading from the ground support
equipment
the team tracked the automated abort to
a software issue
and it was and it was resolved um
nonetheless
launch scrubs for ground systems issues
do uh
sometimes occur as we place mission
success and the safety of our team
and a public all above all other
considerations
um as you as can be seen from the
numerous scrubs this launch was had this
past
week including a delta iv and falcon 9
due to weather and ground system faults
each and every countdown will not always
result in a launch attempt which is just
simply part of the launch
uh launch business um our dr grumman
team is a
is trained to respond professionally to
scrub launch attempts
in order to maintain antares and cygnus
in a safe condition
we always quickly reinvestigate the root
cause if there's any issues and maintain
readiness to launch as
early as the next day i just want to say
what a great work
great teamwork it was by the launch team
last night and this morning to
quickly respond to the scrub launch
attempt and put us back in position to
launch again
less than 24 hours later we are a go for
tonight so we're excited
christina this antares rocket has become
a workhorse for northrop grumman and
contributing to that supply chain for
the international space station
how robust is this vehicle how important
is tonight's launch as we head into a
busy period aboard the international
outpost
so rob ng 14 was designated as a
michigan essential
uh mission by nasa during the covet 19
pandemic and our team has been
focused on being ready on time despite
the additional restrictions and
mitigations put in place to keep our
workforce safe the interior's launch
system and the virginia space launch pad
we are
we both use our designated to be very
robust which has allowed us to achieve
seven consecutive successful antares 230
and 230 plus flights that enabled
successful transmissions to the iss
antares is our 230 plus workforce and we
are carrying cygnus loaded with nearly
eight thousand pounds of cargo tonight
russell grumman is very proud of our
contributions in supplying
critical research and cargo to the crew
on the space station
and for me personally as a native
american from the navajo nation
i am truly honored to be part of our
human exploration program
and i hope to inspire others to reach
for the stars when getting their
setting their goals thank you very much
christina christina hellona of northrop
grumman with us this evening by phone
the countdown for cygnus's launch
now stands a t minus 23 minutes 14
seconds
and counting at the time of launch at 8
16
and 14 seconds pm central time 9 16 14
pm eastern
the international space station and its
three residents will be flying 258
statute miles
over the southern indian ocean antares
and cygnus will arc out
to the southeast from wallops to start
the rendezvous
and a series of pre-programmed engine
firings that will lead
to its arrival at the international
space station and its robotic capture
monday morning
station commander chris cassidy of nasa
backed up by russian cosmonaut
yvonne wagner from roscosmos will be in
the cupola
at the robotic workstation monitoring
cygnus's systems
during its final approach with cassidy
using the
canadarm2 robotic arm to reach out and
grapple
the northrop grumman resupply vehicle
at that point he will turn the robotic
chores over to a team of ground
controllers here in houston
who will maneuver cygnus into an
installation position
to be installed and bolted into place on
the earth-facing side of the unity
module
of the international space station for a
stay of about
two months the cygnus is scheduled to
depart the station
in mid-december for a two-week free
flight in which additional scientific
experiments will be conducted
on board the international space station
cassidy wagner and russian cosmonaut
anatoly ivanishin are asleep at this
hour
less than three weeks away from the end
of their six and a half month mission on
the orbital
outpost they are scheduled to return to
earth on the evening of
october 21st u.s time which will be the
morning of october 22nd on the step of
kazakhstan
for a parachute-assisted landing in
their soyuz ms-16 spacecraft
that will come eight days after the
arrival of the next trio of residents to
the international space station
nasa astronaut kate rubins sergey
rizhikov and sergey kud
zvertkoff of roscosmos who are in final
training right now at the baikonur
cosmodrome in kazakhstan for their
launch on october 14th
in the soyuz ms-17 spacecraft
inside 21 minutes until launch
everything continues to proceed on track
and on time for a liftoff at 8 16
and 14 seconds p.m eastern time
we'll check 379. the uh
ascent profile for uh antares and cygnus
following liftoff calls for main engine
cut off on the first stage of the
antares rocket
about three minutes and 18 seconds after
launch followed six seconds later by the
separation of the first stage
some 30 seconds later the fairing uh
which
encapsulates the cygnus resupply vehicle
will
also separate exposing cygnus uh
during the uphill ride to its
preliminary orbit
stage two ignition on the antares rocket
is scheduled at about the four minute
seven second mark into the flight it
will uh burn for
two minutes and 44 seconds until stage 2
burnout occurs
putting cygnus into its initial orbit
with the cygnus vehicle itself
separating from the second stage of
antares
at about 9 minute nine second mark into
the flight
the ultraflex solar arrays on cygnus are
scheduled uh to be deployed about
two hours and eight minutes into the
mission uh we will not be on the air
live during that activity it's about a
30 minute procedure
we will however provide updates on the
web on nasa.gov and the station blog
site
when solar rate deploy is completed
later this evening
if everything goes as planned cygnus
again will arrive in the wee hours
monday morning at the international
space station
arriving along uh the intersection
called the r bar the radial vector
which is an imaginary line drawn between
uh the international space station and
the earth
that the cygnus will arrive about 400
feet directly below the station and
inch worm its way uh up to the point
where cassidy will use the robotic arm
to reach out and grapple
the resupply craft
the capture of cygnus is scheduled right
now
at 4 20 a.m central time 5
20 a.m eastern time on monday morning
and office ualc countdown
good lc yeah just be advised step 386
will be required for today's op
copy that
nlc this is prop lead actual f1
n level is 10 of 10. copy 10 of 10 381
core 1 provide status on f1 end level
lc core one countdown one standby
as we approach the 17-minute mark into
the countdown
propellant loading is complete you see
the venting uh
at the inter stage area of the
two-stage antares rocket everything
continues
to be green across the board at wallops
the weather is perfect
everything all set for antares to begin
its flight to deliver
the cygnus resupply vehicle to its
preliminary orbit
and cmdlc countdown one
lc core one countdown one go ahead core
one
field level adjustment is not required
copy not required we'll go ahead and
check 382
and prop 2 step 383 configure occs
for no adjustment to fuel level
cmdlc countdown one
lc the cmd yeah you go for step 385 you
can transfer sickness to launch mode
two you'll see this is prop two on
countdown one
occs configured for no adjustment to
fuel level
at t minus 16 minutes and counting those
calls from the range control center
engineers
for northrop grumman indicate that the
fuel loading
for the antares rocket is at the proper
level into stable replenish now
no adjustment for fuel required this
evening and cygnus is about to go on
internal power tonight's launch kicks
off a very busy
period of activity at the international
space station again
a launch tonight uh results in cygnus
arriving at the station in the wee hours
monday morning that will be followed
in a couple of weeks by a soyuz crew
rotation as we mentioned
with kate rubins of nasa and her two
russian crewmates
scheduled to launch october 14th from
the baikonur cosmodrome in kazakhstan
for a two-orbit rendezvous a three-hour
fast-track
journey to the international space
station that will us
kick off an eight-day handover with
chris cassidy
and his two russian crewmates anatoly
ivanishin and yvonne wagner who we said
a moment ago
are in the home stretch of their six and
a half month mission
on the station they'll be returning to
earth on the night of october 21st
u.s time and right on the heels of that
on october 31st on the 20th
just pass through t-minus 15 minutes
we'll be coming up on our
polling for our final county uh
proceeding with our final countdown in
just about
two minutes
on the 20th anniversary of uh the launch
of expedition one
bill shepard yuri godzenko and sergey
krikalov
on october 31st the crew one mission is
scheduled to launch
aboard a spacex falcon 9 rocket
the uh resilience uh crew dragon
spacecraft
with mike hopkins victor glover shannon
walker and soichi niguchi
on board scheduled to arrive at the
international space station on november
1st
t-minus 14 minutes and counting
and cmd i'll wait for your call on 387
lc this is cnbc this is in launch mode
and nominal
copy that cmd we'll check step 387
complete
here in the international space station
flight control room a final go has been
passed on
to flight director tj creamer by the
cygnus mission director in dulles
both antares and cygnus are go for
launch
at this hour the international space
station flying uh
258 miles over the south atlantic
about to swing just to the south of the
continent of africa
again at the time of launch at 8 16 and
14
seconds p.m central time the station and
its three residents who are asleep at
this hour will be flying over the
southern
indian ocean step 388
at this time i want to pull to proceed
with final countdown
gso gso go rso
rsos go pd td is go
prop lead properly just go stage one
stage one let's go mes1 mes one is go
gce gc is go ace
aces go mars mars is go
cmd cmd is go ld
ld is go ng in honor of kaufman traveler
whose research on astronaut health and
safety during space flight
helped pave the way for humans to live
and work in space
northrop grumman is go copy that
northrop grumman we are go to proceed
with final countdown check step 388
ops 2 lc be advised step 389 is not
required for today's operation step 390
will not be required for today's
operation
and ops two copies coming up on the
t-minus 11-minute mark that final poll
for launch conducted at the range
control center
at the wallops flight facility in
virginia
as antares is set to begin its journey
of about nine minutes in duration to
deliver the
cygnus resupply craft to its preliminary
orbit
and passing t minus 11 minutes
coming up on the t minus 10 minute mark
fuel loading complete
the weather is perfect everything is all
set to begin the journey of
cygnus to the international space
station
and t minus 10 minutes
no issues being worked in the range
control center
at wallops island virginia or at
dulles virginia where the cygnus
spacecraft team for northrop grumman
monitoring
cygnus systems ready to take over at the
time of spacecraft separation just over
nine minutes after launch
and ops one step 391 enable acs vdms
lc ops one acs vdm's internal power on
acs dms enabled voltage nominal and
commands cleared
copy that elect one check 391 check 392.
and launching be advised step 393 will
not be required for today's operation
once cygnus arrives at the international
space station in the wee hours monday
morning and
is grappled and then installed and
bolted into place a series of leak
checks
at the birthing interface
between cygnus and the unity module will
be conducted
by nasa astronaut and station commander
chris cassidy
uh making sure that we have a tight seal
between the cygnus and the station
before he begins the process of opening
the hatch
to cygnus and the start of the unloading
of uh
the most uh time critical experiments
and supplies that are being brought up
uh
on the cygnus resupply vehicle
coming up on the seven and a half minute
mark until launch
passing through seven minutes until
launch
t-minus seven minutes
power supplies
396 from 397.
t-minus six minutes and counting
northrop grumman preparing to provide
friday night lights down the eastern
seaboard
everything is go for launch lc
site control ecs transfer gn2 confirmed
roger that side control check step 3.98
and launching be advised step 399 not
required for today's operation
coming up on the t-minus five-minute
mark
t minus five minutes ops one transfer
avionics in turtle power
lc ops one avionics internal power on
standby for command completion
lc ops 1 external power off
internal power is nominal roger like one
ops one open sts envelope
lc ops one fps envy loop open and green
lc elect 2 fplu and fps receiver
indications
are nominal copy elect 2 ops 1 you go to
send all arm command
lc ops 1 all arm command sent
odms alarm nasa tv
tv report range status lc td range is
green
t-minus four minutes and counting
everything in order
no issues being worked at the range
control center at wallops
and launching be advised phase three
dynamic limits
will be active at t-minus three minutes
fc commanded to fight mode
t-minus three minutes and counting
auto sequence start odm bus voltages and
currents nominal
copy all elect one tnt one verify ready
for nav mode
lc gnc one or never even
roger that ops 2 step 414 switch to nav
lc alpha 2 orb nav switch to nav
copy that ops 2 check 414 lcd unc 1 or
m2 verified
roger that tnt one
coming up on the t-minus two minute mark
and terry's systems in
excellent shape no issues
t-minus two minutes on my mark
mark
90 seconds until launch
t-minus one minute 30 seconds
t-minus one minute
well into the terminal count t-minus 50
seconds and counting
t-minus 30 seconds mark
t minus 15 seconds
t minus ten
five four three two
one
engines start and lift off the ss culp
no traveler takes flight
sights set on the international space
station
pitch and roll programmer in
no
engines are steady and nominal 100
altitude 20 000 feet one minute into the
flight everything looking good on
antares
passing through max q attitude nominal
engine's at 100 and terry is passing
through the area of maximum dynamic
pressure
50 000 feet
attitude nominal all vehicles subsystems
are nominal
coming up on the two minute mark into
the flight everything looking good
just passing one hundred thousand feet
add a few nominal
vehicle subsystems nominal
engines remain at 100 attitude nominal
vehicle subsystems nominal good reports
from the range control center at wallops
30 seconds to throttle down throttle
down
is the precursor to main engine cutoff
for the first stage
coming up on the three minute mark into
the flight
engine's at 55 thrust standing by for
main engine cut off on the first stage
main engine cutoff
stage one separation attitude nominal
stage one separation confirmed from the
range control center
and teres flying straight and true
until proper conditions for fairing
separation and stage
ignition are achieved
fairing separation confirmed
cygnus now exposed to the atmosphere as
it
continues its trek uphill to its
preliminary orbit
h2 ignition
this will be about a two minute 44
second burn of the second stage engine
attitude nominal
attitude nominal vehicle subsystems
nominal 140 kilometers
coming up on the five minute mark into
the flood
all systems continue continue nominal
altitude 150 kilometers
all systems nominal the second stage
burnout
is scheduled at about the six minute 51
second
mark into the flight
altitude 170 kilometers roughly one
minute to stage two burnout
altitude 184 kilometers
all systems nominal roughly 30 seconds
to stage two burnout
six minutes 40 seconds into the flight
standing by for
stage two burnout